>> Tucker: WELCOME BACK TO
TONIGHT SPECIAL, INSIDE THE
ISSUES.
THE AMERICAN CIVIL RIGHTS
ORGANIZATIONS USE TO CARE ABOUT,
WELL, CIVIL RIGHTS, NO SURPRISE.
BUT RECENTLY THE NAACP HAS SAID
IT REGARDS CLIMATE CHANGE'S
CIVIL RIGHTS ISSUE AND THAT
EQUALITY CANNOT BE ACHIEVED
WITHOUT ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE,
WHATEVER THAT IS.
WE SPOKE WE SPOKE TO PORTIA
SHEPPARD ABOUT THIS.
SO, IT'S A LITTLE BIT CONFUSING
FOR A COUPLE OF REASONS, THE
MOST OBVIOUS IS, I AGREE WITH
BOTH GOALS, A CLEANING,
ENVIRONMENTAL AND RACIAL
EQUALITY, BUT IT'S HARD TO SEE
EXACTLY WHY THEY ARE TIED
TOGETHER.
HOW ARE THEY?
>> WELL I CAN'T SPEAK FOR THE
NAACP BUT WHAT I CAN SPEAK FOR
IS THE ENVIRONMENTAL INJUSTICE
THAT WE HAVE HERE IN THE BLACK
BELT OF ALABAMA.
PART OF IT IS AS IT RELATES TO
WHAT DR. KING STOOD FOR, HE
STOOD FOR JUSTICE, AND STAND UP
FOR INJUSTICE THAT IS HAPPENING
IN ALL KINDS OF COMMUNITIES.
WHEN YOU LOOK HERE IN THE GREAT
STATE OF ALABAMA, IT'S NOT JUST
IN THE BLACK BELT OF ALABAMA, IT
JUST SO HAPPENS THAT IN LAWRENCE
JUST SO HAPPENS THAT IN LAWRENC
LAWRENCE COUNTY THEY ARE
EXPERIENCING THE SAME FIGHT AS
IT RELATES TO THE ENVIRONMENT OF
INJUSTICES.
IT HAPPENS IN OUR COMMUNITY, THE
MAJORITY OF PEOPLE FACING THESE
PROBLEMS ARE PEOPLE OF COLOR.
>> Tucker: OKAY BUT BY THAT
STANDARD, COULD YOU SAY
MARTIN LUTHER KING FOUGHT FOR
JUSTICE, AND HE DID?
AND IS UNJUST FOR THE GOVERNMENT
TO TAKE MOST OF WHAT YOU HAVE
EARNED -- I THINK YOU AGREE THEY
SHOULDN'T TAKE MOST OF IT.
SO MARTIN LUTHER KING WOULD BE
IN FAVOR OF LOWER TAX RATES.
BUT HE DIDN'T TALK ABOUT LOWER
TAX RATES OR OF GLOBAL WARNING
SO MAYBE WE SHOULDN'T GET HIM
INVOLVED IN THOSE ISSUES?
>> AS IT RELATES TO INJUSTICE,
THE LEGACY OF WHAT
DR. KING STOOD FOR, THAT'S THE
SAME MESSAGE THAT WE ARE SENDING
IN THE TOOLS WE ARE USING IN
THIS FIGHT FOR ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE.
WHEN YOU TIME AND TIME AGAIN
HAVE A COMMUNITY IS ESPECIALLY
IN BLACK BELT OF ALABAMA THAT
DON'T HAVE EQUITABLE SEWAGE, YOU
HAVE PEOPLE BEING POISONED.
YOU WOULD THINK THIS WOULD BE A
CIVIL RIGHTS ISSUE BECAUSE A LOT
OF THE PEOPLE BEING AFFECTED ARE
PEOPLE OF COLOR.
SO IN THAT ASPECT OF IT, I CAN
DEFINITELY UNDERSTAND THAT.
>> Tucker: I CAN SORT OF SEE
WHAT YOU'RE SAYING, NO DOUBT
THAT POOR PEOPLE LIVE IN CRUMMY
OR PLACES AND THAT ARE MORE
POLLUTED.
BUT THERE ARE OBVIOUS REASONS
FOR THAT, SOME OF THEM SINISTER,
I AGREE.
BUT THE MOST POLLUTED PLACES ON
EARTH, THE UKRAINE WHERE THE
CHERNOBYL ACCIDENT HAPPENED,
IT'S NOT A RACIAL ISSUE BUT IT'S
A CONSPIRACY TO POLLUTE BECAUSE
OF SKIN COLOR.
IF WE DON'T HAVE EVIDENCE THAT'S
TRUE, WE PROBABLY SHOULDN'T
SUGGEST IT, RIGHT?
>> I AGREE TO A CERTAIN EXTENT,
BUT AS FAR AS A CLASS POINT, I
ABSOLUTELY AGREE.
THAT'S ONE REASON I BROUGHT UP
LAWRENCE AND MACON COUNTY.
THAT'S UP TO HIM PREDOMINATELY
WHITE COUNTY BUT THE MEDIAN
INCOME IS BETWEEN TEN AND
$17,000 PER YEAR.
YOU HAVE TO SAY THIS IS
DEFINITELY A POINT OF CLASS.
IT'S NOT SO MUCH THAT WE WANT TO
LIVE IN A POOR AREA BUT ME
PERSONALLY, I CAN TESTIFY FOR
MYSELF, I INHERITED LAND IN THAT
PARTICULAR AREA AND I'M NOT
GOING TO GIVE IT UP BECAUSE IT'S
A POOR AREA.
IT'S UNFAIR ESPECIALLY FOR THAT
PARTICULAR COMMUNITY, WHERE YOU
HAVE THE MAJORITY OF THE PEOPLE
WHO LIVE THERE THAT I OWNED THAT
LAND HAVE TO GIVE IT UP BECAUSE
YOU HAVE POLITICIANS AND PEOPLE
WHO ARE IN POWER WHO MAKE
DECISIONS WHO DUMP THESE
PARTICULAR ISSUES ON THEM.
THAT'S ONE OF THE PARTS THAT
BLACK BELT CITIZENS IS FIGHTING.
IT'S NOT SO MUCH, OH, IT CIVIL
RIGHTS, ITS BLACK POWER.
IT'S NOT ABOUT THAT, IT'S ABOUT
HELPING PEOPLE STAND UP FOR
THEMSELVES AND GET THE JUSTICE
THAT THEY DESERVE.
THEY DESERVE CLEAN WATER.
MY MOM HAD NO BUSINESS BUYING
THREE OR FOUR CASES OF WATER PER
WEEK SO SHE COULD COOK A MEAL
BECAUSE SHE WAS AFRAID TO DRINK
THE WATER COMING OUT OF THE
FAUCET.
THOSE THINGS SHOULD NOT BE
HAPPENING.
AND IT JUST SO HAPPENS THAT WHEN
YOU TALK ABOUT CIVIL RIGHTS
ISSUES, YOU SEE IT IN UNIONTOWN
ALABAMA, THESE ISSUES ARE
DEFINITELY TAKING PLACE.
IT JUST SO HAPPENED IN THAT
AREA, ITS PEOPLE OF COLOR BUT
IT'S DEFINITELY A CLASS ISSUE.
>> Tucker: I HAVE TO SAY, I
AGREE WITH A LOT OF WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING.
AND I HOPE THAT YOU DON'T SELL
YOUR LAND BECAUSE SOME OF THE
PRETTIEST PLACES IN THIS COUNTRY
ARE RURAL AREAS.
>> AND THEY ARE A LOT SAFER.
[LAUGHS]
>> Tucker: SAFER AND NICE
PEOPLE.
BUT MAYBE THE PEOPLE IN CHARGE
IGNORE AND EXPLOIT RURAL
AMERICA, DID YOU EVER THINK OF
THAT?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
THAT GOES BACK TO THE CLASS
STATEMENT THAT YOU MADE EARLIER,
IT GOES RIGHT BACK TO THAT.
EVEN THOUGH I AM AND DURING THE
SAME STUFF THAT YOU ARE ENDURING
BUT I HAVE A LITTLE BIT MORE
THAN YOU, I CAN FEEL LIKE I'M
ABOVE IT AND THAT'S THE BIGGEST
ISSUE OF THEM ALL.
THAT'S WHAT DR. KING WAS ABOUT.
THAT CAMPAIGN HE WAS GETTING
READY TO KICK OFF BEFORE HIS
ASSASSINATION, IT WAS FOR POOR
PEOPLE.
AND YOU SEE THAT TIME AND TIME
AGAIN, IT IS SPECIFICALLY IN
POOR COMMUNITIES, AND MORE THAN
LIKELY, PEOPLE OF COLOR WILL BE
AFFECTED BY THAT.
>> Tucker: I KIND OF AGREE
WITH WHAT YOU ARE SAYING.